[Music]
hello my name is Joanne calico I am an
18-year old national master from st.
Louis Missouri and today I prepared a
special lecture for you this evening
I guess the overarching theme is
maneuvering but the recurring theme is
actually at the move Knight a1 I the
reason why it's not everyone is I have a
friend his name is Dennis Norman he
recently broke experts and he has he has
this position against a play rated over
2,000 I think at the world open and he
played the worst possible move which is
all night a1 and all right
it is it is black to move I'll pose this
as a small problem for you it is black
to play and basically win this doesn't
win material but it makes sure that
white cannot move any of his pieces
anybody like to suggest the move
all right they they are perplexed so
Bishop a4 is the answer and the night on
a1 is overruled by the bishop on it for
it cannot move to the rest of the game
and actually he lost very quickly so
after the game he was like well Julian
you know 91 is such a bad move I bet
there is no gain ever plays ever where
91 was the best move or that it was a
brilliant game and this entire lecture
is dedicated to destroying Denis
Norman's reputation so let's let's let's
move on to the Grandmaster games so this
let's just move through the opening
quickly because this isn't an opening
lecture this is the knight wharf with a
six the english attack with Bishop III
e5 is the most common movie six is a
sideline whatever v3 Bishop e6 three so
h5 95 so why it tries to play
positionally against h5 because it gives
away the g5 square and now he's going to
play with a queen sized majority later
so nineteen seven Queen d2 this this is
not the important part
so c4 white is gaining space on the
Queen side and instead of trying to
check my like he doesn't normal lines of
the English attack he's just going to
castle and play on the Queen side
because he has more space over there and
you play on the side that you your
strong set so Bishop g7 castles castles
rooks t1 and in this position sorry hold
on in this position white as our a b6
well it has a very interesting maneuver
which everybody at home should know
because my my rule which I've
established as the newest lecturer at
the st. Louis chess club is always play
Knight a1 X clamp
91 and this is a novelty played by these
guys Alexei Alexei volt and Jared didn't
I
Sarah did being me whenever Robert in
2013 but this idea was actually
validated by Wesley so played against
Dominguez in 2014 and here on the point
of 9a one is I want to play b4 and maybe
run my night back or I can bring my
knight to c6 and it'll be very useful on
c6 and maybe in some lines it will end
up on the Kings side so it's important
in chess not to be so dogmatic like
Knight a 1 is not a very good move in
most positions but you want to look at
the you want to look at the whole board
and I and what for opportunities even if
they seem unusual or bad so neither one
is obviously very unusual but ok black
responded the end the most in the most
normal way for this position the point
can anybody try to explain the point of
teenage 7 for black
so black has a problem in this position
would anybody like to point out the
problem so black has pawns on d6 and
ePHI which are kind of fixed and I mean
he likes at some point maybe to play e4
but some if the pawns remain on d6 + e5
then his bishop is always going to be
bad on g7 so the point of teenage 7 is
at some point he'd like to play Knight
g8 and Bishop h6 and trade off a pair of
bishops because of thumb because the
bishop would be pinned to the Queen on
this diagonal so that's why black played
teenage seven-night c2 so Ramona Vereen
unfortunately the knight to not remain
on a1 forever and I mean that's life but
but here here it finds it's trying to
find his way to greener pastures like c6
or maybe or maybe eventually in g2 so
Knight 98 isn't it's important to note
the old move here was actually g4 and
White was probably a little bit better
in these lines after 95 and Bishop d3 he
has slightly more space so he has
slightly more space in the center he has
this pawn which is controlling the f5
Square and he has two bishops
but that being said black is very solid
and has pressure alone the B line and at
some point can try to play a 5 and a 4
and there's or maybe organized f5 and in
his dreams
so like this position is very
complicated and there's a lot of counter
play for black which is why this novelty
night a1 is actually very very strong so
let's continue so nigh g8 the point of
98 obviously is to prepare Bishop h6
because the bishop on g7 is bad due to
the structure on
in the center so you play g4 so hgg for
is has two ideas the the first idea is
you kind of you kind of want to make f5
less desirable so at some point if you
played Bishop d3 or like the F file if
the F file opens then F is going to be
harder to achieve if you play f5
immediately then um I I'll just leave my
pawns B and I'll try to win on winning
on the on the kingside through the H
file or something like that eventually
I'll prepare F for myself and I have two
bishops so when the center opens up
hopefully I'll be the one with the
better position so in this the second
idea sorry yeah the first idea is you
want to make f5 less desirable the
second one is maybe you'll try to take
on h5 open the G file and boys pieces
will come floating in so h g4 FG
this might be a small concession because
white rook
all of a sudden becomes very active in
this position with the pawn being on f3
the rook doesn't really do anything but
after but black was afraid of G H so he
he had to he had to play this move now
97 91 so if we were to if we were to
bring our knight to c6 re our knight
cannot go to c6 so we have to change our
plans and this is like the whole idea of
night I want like you can't be so
dogmatic you can't say okay well I play
Knight a1 because I want to go to c6 or
I want to win on the Queen side the
situation can change so now it's
probably better to have your pieces on
the Kings side because black has
weakened that part of the board so 91e
for 90 to 95 black is black it's played
efore because now as bishop which which
i was criticizing the entire game is is
kind of a monster the bishop controls
the entire diagonal
although the static structure would
indicate that you would want it you
would want to trade these bishops so if
why it would a play Bishop before then
then Bishop takes and Queen c5 probably
black is significantly better already
just because the dark square Bishop have
been traded and potentially he can have
a protected passed pawn with that five
so white doesn't want to trade dark for
bishops but at the same time the black
has improved the bishop on g7
tremendously so 92 yeah so now now the
blacks weakened the King sight we want
to put our pieces over there so the
knight has found a very nice home on G -
maybe we're preparing h4 and h5 95 Black
has put his knight on on a very active
position or active looking but actually
in my opinion 95 is a mistake probably
what I should do is try to organize some
kind of counter play with like rook b8
and b5 or f5 somehow but after Knight e5
this allows a very creative move if at
home you might want to take 20 seconds
and pause and try to try to find this
month what what was what did black
prevent before he played 95 hopefully
you took some time and the answer is
rook c3 now the rook that came from a
one actually wants to end up here as I
said black is weak in the Kings side so
we go and we put our pieces over there
an attack so we're going to bring our
work to h3 with the night beam on d7 of
course the bishop would take the rook in
black is one material I mean I don't
know how how much but better black
actually is but in exchanges in exchange
so at least at least you could consider
the shift c3 so 95 rook c3 he's coming
to h3 obviously rook b8 so now black is
trying to play b5 but probably it was
better better back here with cancel
95 works III work the 850 for Queen d7
he's trying to I the G 4 square but this
this already doesn't doesn't doesn't
matter as much
I mean the king is too weak so rook h3
here and now once again a white made a
very interesting decision here what
would you play here with white at home I
would take 10 seconds
do you have any ideas so so so what
you'd like to play is Queen h6 the
problem with Queen h6 is Bishop is
Bishop h6 right so can you force a
concession from black right now
I'm just going to continue the answer is
Bishop takes e5 takes and now White has
a very nice connect to passed pawn and
also he's made this Bishop on g7
significantly weaker Bishop takes
obviously is not possible because Queen
h6 comes with mate you really can't stop
queen h7 conveniently the only thing you
can do is give a check and then here
it's already over queen h7 is basically
unstoppable so well I mean you could
move the rook and get mated on f7 I
guess
so take Queen e1 the point of Queen e1
is obviously to get on the H file and
then Queen e7 a queen h7 is annoying
again so f6 never play off six except
except here because he wants to run away
that's too little too late in h1 just
just in case there's any check along
this diagonal at some points getting out
of future tactics and maybe at some
point the rook will be useful on g1 be
593 so the night that was on a1 actually
finds itself on the best best possible
position the 93 is is very very nice
if you can do this in your games it's
it's useful to keep in mind when there's
when there's like a pawn on d4 or d5 if
black were to play like Knight to c8 to
d6 or in this case my g2 to e3 and block
a these pawns then usually the knight
can serve as both a defensive piece
stopping the pawn from moving and an
attacking piece stuff well in this case
of stopping the pawn but and sometimes
they can go to d5 or f5 it's just very
useful to blockade pawns like this this
is one of like integrins oh this is a
very common theme and here been denied
it
the night is the best piece on the board
so 93 Queen d6 d4 white is going to
expand on the Queen side with d5 and d6
and the d7 and c6 and c7 c8 all the
pawns are storming down the board white
is winning on all sides of the board he
has the H file black can't really play a
5 it conveniently because it all opened
up this King too much for like for
example after before if f5 it's probably
all over after Queen h4 I'm going to
play Queen h7 and take the pawn on f5
and take back so that's why BC 4 was
played night c4 attacking the Queen
Queen d7 Queen before was not played
because you get made it simple so d6 95
Bishop d1 the point of Bishop do you
want is to come to b3 and once once you
reach this diagonal it's I mean it's
basically lights-out
yeah black is totally lost here already
Knight of for Bishop b3 if you take the
rook obviously there's 95 check winning
a queen so Ric f7 rook back to C 3 e3
queen e3 and actually a black resigned
here because I'm about to play Knight a5
and when the exchange and not only that
I'm also making a queen and maybe I can
think about mating you on the H file
later so this game this game was pretty
destructive I mean it's clear proof that
night a1 is almost the best move in
every variation that this was played
between two grandmasters rated about 25
50 all right now the second game like to
show is even better it's between Magnus
Carlsen and Michael Adams
and this is actually not only my
favorite game were night anyone was
played with my favorite game of all time
it's very traditional
so Carlton is white he starts with d4
Knight f6 c4 e6 93 it should be 4 so
this is the nimzo-indian and the
classical variation with Queen c2 Adams
responded with d5
there are many moves here with white
Carlsen chose a 3 Bishop c3 Queen c2 3
and then the whole point of this
variation is obviously not to double
your pawns with vc 3 you protected the
night with the Queen and Bishop f4
attacking c7 so ship a6 is played this
is a pawn sacrifice which is actually
very interesting yeah this one it move
this oil all right cool so in this
position um I mean this is just theory
lots of lots of Grandmaster games have
been played so I have reached this
specific position and most of them have
been drawn the best move here is knight
c6 eat and Knight f3 rook c8 and then
you'll play the idea is to play Knight
a5 but okay first you play 94r sorry
castles rugby 194 III take take in 95
and this this is roughly equal because
white has lots of white square
weaknesses on B 3 C 4 C 2 black and hope
to invade with his ropes and he'll have
at least enough compensation for the
pawn instead Adams played castles here
which is probably slightly inaccurate
although maybe it doesn't matter because
I'll play 96 anyway but his idea was
wrong he played knight of 3 and rook c8
now actually this rook belongs on d8 and
the rook on a a the loans on c8 but he
wanted immediate to counter play with
rook c8 to c2 so he wanted to hit b2 and
I mean if he wins if you went to column
B 2 then black is probably already
fighting for the advantage
I mean Black has more development
development than white so if material is
equal then then he's already on the
attack sorry
so rook c8 Bishop f4 97 and here Carlson
recognizes that though he is up a pawn
he has a lot of problems 97 is the wrong
idea because the knight doesn't really
have a good Square after it goes to d7
on c6 is going to a 5 B 3 and C 4 and on
d7 it's it can't go to HC fiber or a5
but but here the knight on f3 kind of is
kind of in the way because you'd really
like to play F 3 and E 4 or you'd like
to you'd like to develop your other your
other pieces and there's actually a
problem here that the black is
immediately playing Rick C 2 so he tries
to resolve all his problems with 92
which is probably correct other
interesting lines are for example king d
194 Fischer g3 Rick c6 III take take
Rick C 891 b5 and white is slightly
better but the position that he got in
the game is better than this so probably
what he did I mean we needed was fine
that's both plans are okay for white so
92 Rick c2 rook b1 rook c8 93 and
everybody at everybody at home should
know the move here it's a knight a 1
sorry Bishop c4 Knight a1 which actually
conveniently traps the rook because
there can't go back but Adams saw this
probably and he was relying on bishop
eat a two takes takes and now of course
the knight is hit and if it goes to like
III or something then rook c1 and I
don't know rook back and Knight you for
2 f2 is probably going to be annoyed so
so once again Carlson plays Knight a1 so
the reason why this is the best game
ever is first of all Carlson managed to
play 91 twice and you didn't lose and 91
is the best move and the only move that
maintains the advantage 95 Bishop d2 so
a black kind of forced white to do
something he wanted to do anyway
probably ok 95s fine but White's going
to play Bishop d2 an e3 and then try to
castle and claim use up upon but here
black played I mean he's just kind of
playing into White's hands
95 by 52 he okay you want to open up the
center when your opponent is poorly
developed all of whites pieces on the on
the last rank but it doesn't matter
because Queens are traded and the
initiative is kind of kind of gone so
III take take
ricky-ricky 8 sorry tonight be a knight
of fate is also interesting but here I
can play like Bishop a6 and try to I
mean he maintains two bishops the pawn
is an attack yet I can try to move my
king somewhere and play Knight b3 and
I'm up a pawn but it might be it so uh
as what was played in the game what
what's going on okay all right so night
b8 e f3 knight c6 Bishop c4 so Carlsen
attacks the night to try to so I mean
black just attacked a pawn but Carlsen
attack tonight so black needs to respond
to that and he he develops with tempo so
he's going to keep his pawn rook e8 I
can f2 so obviously if you take this guy
then I'll take your Bishop and you'll
probably resign so Bishop f5 Knight B 3
now Bishop e6 was played Rick C 1 F 6
now here in this position white played a
very very short note so white has a has
protected as pawn sufficiently he's um
he's put his work on the only open file
I mean sorry I was I mean the most
important open file the e-file doesn't
really matter because the Kings can can
guard it all of his pieces kind of makes
up the knight doesn't really make sense
because there's there's pause you're
stopping it's its future Holmes but here
Carlson tries to provoke a weakness and
he plays a four which is very very
strong now this move might not like be
important right now but like ten ten
moves from now or 15 moves from now this
is really gonna it's really going to
benefit white because if I'm allowed to
play a five and take and move my wrote
to the a file then I have entry points
on let's say a six or a seven and if
black does what he did in the game and
he plays a five then B six all of a
sudden becomes extremely weak so Carlson
has changed his game plan here now now
instead of trying to hold on to this
pawn we what we want to do is we want to
try to attack these six and well the
bishop that black doesn't have the dark
square Bishop so it's actually kind of
convenient if we would if we were to
loser loser d4 pawn so Bishop c3
obviously black can't take because I
take on e6 with check and take on c3 and
black resigns so Bishop f7 92 997 Bishop
f1 so if you were if you were to play
something like rook d1 and try to hold
on to your pawn I mean obviously you
can't take this like because of tactics
right I just take and play Knight B 3
and when the piece on d4 but you're
going to run into some difficulties
after just Bishop c4 ends black black
has really nice control over d5 white
will never be able to advance the pawn
before he has excellent excellent
control of the light squares and whites
Bishop is no good so
this is unclear probably why it's a
little bit better but you have to play
the ship f1 if you want to maintain your
advantage but black blacks took back to
spawn but after Knight takes d4 this
diagonal has suddenly opened up so
blacks sorry White's pawn on d4 was
actually stopping the dark square bishop
from being on its best possible diagonal
the g1 to a7 diagonal so Ricky 196 94 so
now the night is attacking blacks only
weakness 95 and this is another very
important moment Black is about to take
on c3 and the most natural movements
Bishop d2 but you actually have a have a
much stronger move in this position - to
prevent Knight takes c3 I would
recommend taking 10 seconds to try to
find this move it's it's very nice the
work on e 1 isn't really doing anything
it doesn't have any entry points into
blacks position it doesn't really do
anything on c1 because black and guard
all those squares but if we play with v1
now black can't take on c3 because b6
will be hanging at the end so like
Knight c3 loses 2 takes and you can't
defend b6 you take care I take with
check and I take on b6 and your entire
structure collapses all play route 66
work could be 500k 5 completely winning
for white so Cain f8 bishop v1 now
Carlson revenue versus Bishop to attack
blacks only weakness on v6 87 King g1
normally you want to bring your king to
the center in the ending which is
something that clearly Michael Adams was
taught but Carlson brenda's came back
because actually it's more of a tactical
vulnerability on e2 than anything else
so it's better on g1 than a different
square and the bishop comes two up to
more important to activate your other
pieces in York in this specific position
so Knight be a bishop F 297 rook e1 and
rook d1 so Carlsen just repeated it's
better to have your work on anyone so
Ricky ones a good new work new ones just
because he wants to get closer to time
control this is move 38 and he got to
move 39 I would assume that move 40 is
time control where they get an
additional hour or something so he's
just making sure that he doesn't lose on
time and then 96 so white goes after
black Bishop now I I will in the game
Adams play 95 but I will give you the
opportunity to solve this tactic it is
white to play in win material is anybody
brave enough
there are two ways of doing it
okay hopefully you took some time to try
to figure it out the correct solution is
Bishop c5 or okay
it doesn't matter ninth Knight f7 it
transposes Bishop c5 we take both of the
minor pieces and then we plug Bishop c4
and then rook t1 end after King Keaney 6
+ f4 black is going to lose the knight
on d5 eventually I'm just going to bring
Mike into u 4 and the pin is not going
away ever this is a pin forever black
and try g5 g 3 but it's just over I'm
going to bring my king before if you
stop me all I'll put my king I don't
know like I'll play Rick T 3 and put my
and the Queen side and when they came up
on ending or something so this position
is totally lost
so instead Adams plate 95 nine of seven
kf7 the two bishops are very powerful in
the ending and more importantly the b6
pawn is very weak so roof d1 Bishop 66
is already a threat because the depend
on the D file so kt7 to stop the ship
takes b6 here sorry white plate up for
because the pollen on f3 wasn't so
important but this pawn on b6 is very
important if I get to take on d8 and
play Bishop 6 b6 and Bishop takes like 5
I have 2 connected passed pawns on the
Queen side and bishops work very well on
an open board in addition to the fact
that there are pawns on both sides of
the board making this completely winning
ending for white so night on i-24 rook
e1 can FA Bishop d4 so wrote d6 was
played
now the knight can move with a discovery
on the bishop h3 and Rick d1 now an even
simpler tactic here it is white to play
in win material so why can white not and
sorry why can't black not take on it for
that is correct the ship c5 immediately
went it takes then I take on d6 and
black and basically resign I'm playing
route k-6 and working five I'm up to the
exchange yeah for 2800 this is easy
so Knight takes F sorry 9604 was not
played night of five was played black is
trying to eliminate White's most
important piece so Bishop f2 obviously
King e7 so now but I can think about 93
or something
g4 uh yeah actually 93 a media there was
a tricky one
they ignore that last comment was total
nonsense Knight age six f5 yeah then I
can't really move I fixed the king's
head structure a little bit and b6 is
just going to be lost after Bishop e2 so
now I'm 52 night a for take take and
Bishop e6 yeah this position is totally
totally over but I guess it's worth
going over Carlson's technique anyway
because it's very nice heat he just
gives us pawn away so that he can take a
five so you can't um allow black to take
h3 so you just take on a five and out of
the two bishops you might want to
consider which one you want to keep and
which one you want to get rid of white
white obviously I mean take 10 seconds
think about it but the answer is the
dark square bishop because blacks pawns
are on f6 and g7
so in any ending or I get to play let's
not that move Bishop f8 I'm going to
like when you're King side pawns and
this pawn is a distraction so if your
King goes over there then my cane might
come in when your games like pawns on f7
so King c5 Bishop King g3 my mistake and
Carlsen doesn't care he doesn't care
about his Bishop on b5 he cares about
the born on on c8 I don't see one so
Bishop c1 was played 90 for take and
Bishop e3
sorry Bishop d2 better would actually
just Bishop a3 this is like +4 already
but what he did was like finance like
pasta to I assume they were in time
trouble
this isn't over 66 a five and why it
just brought his kin to the King site
and the game was over
all right thanks thanks thanks for
watching this was Julian for laïkó and
Dennis mom and I hope you appreciated
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]